There are certain television shows that attract
such a rabid engaged audience that it is impossible
for viewers not develop theories and speculation
concerning the characters and plotlines.
Sometimes a show only becomes more interesting
when reading between the lines and not simply
observing a show at face value.
Here are 10 TV Fan Theories That Make Way
too Much Sense, If you enjoy our list, don’t
forget to like it and subscribe to the Screen
Rant channel.
Buffy the Vampire Slayer
Buffy the Vampire Slayer has ignited many
theories from loyal and dedicated fans of
the Joss Whedon series.
One of the more depressing theories is the
why Buffy’s mom, Joyce developed a brain
tumor that ultimately killed her.
In season five, Buffy gets a younger sister,
Dawn.
This wasn’t a case of the series jumping
the shark with a random new sibling.
Dawn was created by monks.
She was not human but the key to other dimensions.
The monks had to alter the memory of Buffy’s
friends and family to believe Dawn had been
there the entire time.
What if this brain manipulation was too much
for Joyce and caused a tumor?
Buffy is a slayer and can take it, her friends
have less memories to stuff in their mind
but Joyce would have memories since Dawn’s
birth and being pregnant with her.
Was it just too much for Joyce?
How I Met your Mother
For nine seasons, How I Met your Mother sparked
many conversations among fans trying to figure
out who exactly the mother could be.
An exhaustively long tale told to his two
children included so many misleads that the
identity of the mother became a true mystery.
It is another fan theory that makes this list,
one in which Barney’s playbook is Ted’s
playbook.
The playbook which showed a variety of over-the-top
ways to court a woman may seem like something
Barney would write.
However, the version of Barney we see is told
by the unreliable narrator Ted and could just
be a way to avoid telling his kids that he
was the real womanizer.
The playbook being adorned with calligraphy,
a skill Ted is proud to practice, makes it
even more likely that The Playbook is the
work of Ted, and not Barney.
Rugrats
Rugrats holds a special place in the hearts
of many millennials as it was one of the first
Nickelodeon original animated series debuting
in 1991.
The show which features the daily adventures
of a group of infant and toddlers may seem
harmless but the fan theory is downright morbid.
The theory claims that Angelica is the only
real character and that everyone else is a
figment of her imagination.
Chuckie died along with his mother.
The twins were aborted.
Tommy was a stillborn.
This explains why Tommy’s father is always
making toys frantically and Chuckie’s father
is always so anxious.
The fathers can’t seem to accept what has
happened.
It’s a dark take on a kid’s show that
isn’t completely impossible.
The Simpsons
The Simpsons has been a mainstay on Fox since
1989 with no sign of slowing down or diminishing
in quality.
There are plenty of fan theories derived from
nearly three decades of material.
One of theories is that the Simpson family
are geniuses, but one of the most fascinating
theories revolves around Homer being in a
coma since 1993.
In the episode “So It’s Come to This:
A Simpsons Clip Show”, Homer falls into
a coma after being crushed by a vending machine.
Fans speculate that Homer never woke up from
his coma and that the episodes that followed
were all in his mind.
Before Homer became comatose, the episodes
were based in reality, whereas after the coma,
the episodes became outlandish and silly.
This also explains why none of the characters
have aged in the last twenty-plus years.
Friends
For ten seasons fans watched six New Yorker
pals fall in love, break-up, have children,
divorce, all in an unrealistic world of affordable
Manhattan apartment.
While Friends only occasionally delved into
the difficult times of adulthood, one fan
theory claims there was something serious
happening without much discussion, Ross losing
custody of his son, Ben.
The theory stems from Ben practically disappearing
from Ross’s life after season 8.
Ben does not appear for the remaining two
and a half seasons of the series.
He is mentioned casually only a few times,
and Ben never meets his half-sister, Emma.
When considering how insane Ross became in
the later seasons, it makes perfect sense
that Carol would seek out sole custody of
their son.
Ross dated his student, hit on his cousin,
became weirdly possessive of Rachel, and judgmental
over most his friend's life decisions, and
lost his temper at work over a leftover sandwich.
Breaking Bad
For five seasons, audiences watched science
high school teacher Walter White go from family
man to the biggest and most dangerous drug
dealer around.
Breaking Bad itself is filled to the brim
with interlaced stories, character development
and recurring themes, but fans have speculated
that Breaking bad is also a sequel to Malcolm
in the Middle and a prequel to The Walking
Dead.
While the Malcolm in the Middle connection
is more humorous than anything, The Walking
Dead connection holds a lot more weight.
Fans have claimed that Heisenberg’s drugs
caused the zombie outbreak.
In Season 2 of The Walking Dead, Daryl talks
about his brother scoring drugs that are suspiciously
similar to Heisenberg’s signature “Blue
Sky”.
That along with the description of the dealer
sounding an awful lot like Jesse Pinkman makes
this fan theory likely.
Firefly
Firefly is one of the most beloved brilliant
but cancelled television shows ever.
The show which follows a gang of space cowboys,
only aired 11 episodes before being axed.
The fan theory behind Firefly concerns the
real reason Firefly was cancelled.
While the Fox network claimed poor ratings,
fans believe it was the government who wanted
the show removed.
The series aired in 2002 when the Bush administration
was attempting to get everyone behind the
Iraq war, which made a show about intelligent
and resourceful outlaws who fought for civil
rights and peace to be a conflict of interest.
The theory makes some sense considering how
enthusiastic the Firefly fan base is today,
but this could be a case of viewers not realizing
a show’s brilliance until it was too late.
Saved by the bell
The gang from Saved by the Bell seemed like
the coolest high school students ever.
With their covetable 90s wardrobe, close friendships,
and a principal who seemed obsessed with them.
It all seemed a bit too good to be true, which
is exactly why many fans speculated that it
was all in the mind of Zack Morris.
For those who watched the show when it was
called Good Morning, Miss Bliss, you may remember
that Zack wasn’t cool, he was just an average
awkward kid going to junior high in Indiana.
When the show was renamed, it was set in Malibu,
and Zack was suddenly a facsimile of Ferris
Bueller.
Lisa, Screech and Mr. Belding also returned
but the gang was rounded out with Jessie,
Kelly, and Slater, all of who were much cooler
than the friends he had in Indiana.
The fan explanation makes a lot of sense especially
if you consider the wacky events that occurred
on the show to be in the mind of an Indiana
teen who wishes he had a much more interesting
life.
The Office
In season six of The Office, Toby Flenderson,
the sad sap of Human Resources is thrilled
to be on the jury of the Scranton Strangler.
However, fans suspect that it was Toby who
was the real Scranton Strangler all along.
The reason being that Toby’s life was going
nowhere and everyone treated him so poorly
that he finally snapped.
It wasn’t until he returned to Pennsylvania
after having a go living in Costa Rica, when
the Strangler appeared.
In the ninth season Toby admits that he sent
the wrong man to prison and the man accused
of being the strangler attempts to strangle
Toby when he goes to visit.
Was Toby’s guilt for imprisoning an innocent
man because he was the real Scranton Strangler?
The Walking Dead
Ever since The Walking Dead exploded on AMC
in 2010, there has been a fervent following
eliciting countless fan theories and speculations.
One theory that never seems to die is that
Rick is immune to the zombie-causing disease
that has affected those around him.
The origins for this theory comes from the
first episode in which Rick wakes up in a
hospital after being in a coma.
When he was in a coma, his brain had limited
activity resulting in the disease not affecting
him.
Why this makes him completely immune throughout
the show remains unclear.
There is an additional theory that Rick has
been a zombie the entire time and his waking
from a coma was him waking from the dead.
He is fortunate enough not to experience any
of the terrible symptoms associated with zombies
such as the need to eat human brains.
While unlikely, the theory may be on to something.
What do you think of our list?
What are your favorite fan theories?
Leave yours in the comments and don’t forget
to like our list and share it with friends.